i watched congo
a lot the line in this house that is
repeated from that movie the most
i know what the line is stop eating my
sesame cake
i'm like i'm totally serious and asking
you this
what was that scripted and how do you
figure out how to nail
the delivery of a line of dialogue like
that because if
it is iconic yeah it's become a thing
huh um
i'm fairly certain that it was scripted
um and it was another instance in which
i was very well paid for literally one
day of
work um
when i first was offered that part i
believe it was going to shoot in the
dominican republic
and they said the producer said look uh
will you come do this part
um uh we're shooting in the dominican um
you can bring your wife you know you can
film
for a day or two on the film and then
you can
spend some time in the dominican
republic and i said oh great fantastic
yes i'll do the part um
time evolved and we ended up shooting in
pasadena
um uh i did get to bring my wife but we
went to pasadena another dominican
republic
um but the line was scripted and it was
one of those things where i just went in
and um
did the work that was in front of me was
really good actors in the cast
um and we just worked and it just
happened and it's one of those things
that has become
you know your word is iconic it's become
a thing i i'm
clear it's become a thing and it's the
connection that many many people make
for my contribution to that film it's
not even that line though
your entire sequence your delivery kind
of carries it i mean
liar i are saying more it's like teeny
tiny little things that could be
insignificant like that
you make sure it becomes like an ear
worm of sorts because of the way you
deliver it
well thank you i appreciate that and
perhaps
to my earlier point right of not
referring
to bit parts you know it i i guess it's
an example of
how an actor how any of us invests
in the words that are in front of us in
a script
and that will dictate what you get out
of it as an actor in terms of the
creative process
but also the potential impact on
audiences
mr homoka
stop eating my sesame cake
stop eating my sesame cake